[Musique]
serge hoareau conseiller départemental
délégué à l'agriculture reçoit les
représentants syndicaux de la fdsea et
des jeunes agriculteurs au palais de la
source
objectif trouver une solution dans le
blocage qui oppose les planteurs gagner
et tereos sur la renégociation de la
convention calme faire un point avec eux
sur l'état d'avancement des négociations
qui malheureusement aujourd'hui il
n'avance pas et c'est vrai que c'est
inquiétant à quelques jours du début de
la campagne sucrière
les agriculteurs de ces deux syndicats
nous on a interpellé pour aussi essayer
de faire comprendre à l'usinier à tereos
en particulier qu'il est nécessaire et
indispensable qu'on qu'il revienne
autour de la table nous regrettons
puisque les harry potter ont joué le jeu
il ya eu un apaisement ils avaient
arrêté depuis plus de quinze jours
maintenant les manifestations il n'y a
pas eu d'avancée significative à leur
sens et je pense qu'il est bon qu
aujourd'hui de tereos entendre cet appel
qui reviennent autour des tables de
négociations non pas en bilatéral mais
tout le monde autour de la table les
syndicats l'état et tereos autour de la
même table pour essayer d'aboutir sur
cette nouvelle convention canne les
syndicats demandent la revalorisation du
prix de la tonne de canne de 6 euros
un levier qui ne peut être enclenchée
que par l'état et l'ush signé malgré
tout la collectivité souhaite mobiliser
le gouvernement sur cette situation
critique
on a le soutien des ja du département et
surtout ce qui est important c'est que
ils se sont engagés à faire un courrier
commun avec toutes les instances
politiques que peut compter le
département pour alerter le président de
la république et les ministères sur la
situation du conflit entre les planteurs
et tereos au niveau local donc je pense
qu'il est très important plus il y aura
du monde qui parlera de ce conflit plus
il aura décodant les ministes et au
niveau du président pour qu'il y ait
justement bas des réunions constructives
qui se met en place et qu'on continue à
travailler et qu'on avance
près de 200 planteurs se sont installés
devant les grilles de la préfecture
à une semaine du lancement de la
campagne sucrière et après trois mois de
blocage
les planteurs attendent de se retrouver
à nouveau autour de la table des
négociations
[Musique]